welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and we got our first
look at Dune part two and as huge fans
we decided to react and break down the
important parts we think y'all should
know about in this trailer and who
better to join me on our journey back to
arrakis the new Rockstar's number one
Dune fan Zach Huddleston I'm a real
spice head and I am thrilled to be here
oh my God I'm so excited if you watch
the break room you know that Zach loves
Dune so much so we have to break this
down in Dune part 2 we really see Paula
tradies work with Johnny and the other
fremin while trying to avenge his father
and their house after the first movie
left them destitute yes additionally the
first part of this breakdown will be
spoiler free so this book has been out
for about 50 years there's an 80s
version of the movie so it would be very
easy for you to know what's gonna happen
the big plot points of this movie we're
not going to cover those to the end of
this video there's a lot of info that we
can talk about and we're gonna go frame
by frame and try to find out all the fun
hidden details within this also the
great thing about Disney Villeneuve the
director of this film he takes a lot of
Liberties he might change him stuff that
might not be be in the books or previous
adaptations and we're really excited for
that I'm so excited so let's just get
right into it the first time we see Lady
Jessica in the trailer she's in a wicker
basket she's clearly ascended to the
Benny Jester at status of Reverend
mother for the fremen complete with a
face full of tattoos and looks
completely badass director Denny
villeneu recently said those tattoos are
linked with the prophecy lady Jessica is
one of the masterminds of Dune she's
trying to play her own agenda the
meaning of that look would be unveiled
in part two we first saw these tattoos
also in the first dune and Paul's
Visions uh what prophecy is it overall
the like what we were seeing Paul see in
the first movie yeah and then there's
this huge overarching been a Jesuit
prophecy right part of the golden path
right that they they foresee this this
christ-like save your figure is going to
come along and help all of humanity but
then we also have those competing
visions of Paul oh crazy uh look
forwards that he was having in the first
movie oh my God I can't and then also
how do you know if it's true because
have all of them been true oh okay we'll
get we'll get more into this into the
trailer we're introduced to Florence
Pugh as Princess eralon she plays a big
role in the books because each chapter
opens with a quote from her so it's
similar to how she's narrating parts of
this trailer with that recorder included
she's the eldest daughter of the emperor
who's played by Christopher Walken but
we've never seen him in the trailer the
emperor sent a treaties to arrakis in
the first place he has a bigger plan
overall and we don't know if princess
Ireland agrees or disagrees with it
right now yes yeah and we don't get any
clues from this trailer necessarily
about her alignment though she is saying
like What if Paul is not dead yes right
her and Paul's Futures are very
intertwined we'll talk about that a
little bit later she is actually not a
super active character in the books or
in previous movies but it looks like her
role might be increased yeah in this
movie which when you get an actress of
the stature of Florence Pugh you gotta
use it you're not a user so her dad must
know that he's alive if she says what if
he's alive right or is she keeping it a
secret yeah we don't know right and
again the the emperor also is a very
passive unseen figure in the first movie
he's the one kind of pulling the strings
setting how's harconan and a tradies
against each other he kind of doesn't
like either of them and he's hoping they
kind of beat each other up and keep him
powerful in comparison ah this this
politics this game this is is Game of
Thrones meets Star Wars and this is what
I eat up this is what I love we also
have Gurney Gurney is still alive we
didn't know his fate in the first movie
The last time we saw him the soldiers
came down from their ships and they
rushed them but we never really saw what
happened to Gurney what do you think he
was doing in the desert this entire time
so yeah he survived because he's a
badass and you can't kill Josh Brolin
that easily so he's been out there kind
of running a separate campaign with some
other surviving a treaty Soldiers by
doing some guerrilla warfare against the
harkonens who are trying to you know do
the spice operation baby what and he's
gonna and this is a little bit of a
spoiler maybe there's a good cutout but
he reunites with his boy Paul and they
join forces I assumed honestly if we
don't cut this out I completely assumed
he was going to make his way out of the
desert and find Paul again and then
we're introduced to Austin Butler who's
playing fade rotha who is a brother to
Dave Batista's glassu his scenes are
mostly in black and white which is
insane to us and we really spotted this
out in the trailer first off Zach you
run up on some theories to that so what
do you think yes so we did see the our
Conan uh home planet daddy Prime and it
was not black and white it's very
overcast like kind of Blade Runner super
polluted right it's dark but it wasn't
in black and white and so why are we
seeing this in black and white and the
leading theories are either this is
daytime we previously only saw at night
time and when the sun is out it's not
our sun it's some kind of weird crazy
Sun that maybe when filtered through a
polluted atmosphere gives this weird
kind of ultraviolet coloring also could
be this is a gladiator scene where most
of this is taking place right there's
this whole theory that like the only
thing that can be a challenge for him is
to like fight in the dark and so he's
actually fighting this other Gladiator
in the dark and it's the audience that
are all looking through like kind of
night vision goggles and that's why it's
that look this also could be it could
all be flashback right we know there's
gonna be maybe some kind of framing
device around the princess talking about
things that have happened in the past so
maybe this is either her talking about
events that have already taking place
something like that I love that I want
it to be the people looking through the
binoculars the most that in the dark
that is so insane I would love that and
another thing I want to point out about
this kind of battle scene in the black
and white right this is a very famous
scene from the book and I think in first
glance it looks like two harkonens
fighting but fade rotha is in the black
right he's fighting the shirtless
character I think that shirtless
character is not our opponent I think
that's actually a captured a tradie
soldier Okay in the in the books that's
who it is the gentleman Roger Yuan I
believe I'm pronouncing his name wrong
uh who is the fight coordinator design a
lot of the fighting styles for this uh
for the first film he's a brief Cameo as
this lieutenant lanville in the first
movie that sun coordinator has has done
interviews where he's talked about like
that was a little Easter egg because
they're gonna have him come back in the
second movie I think that's who that is
he is old actor who's actually an of
Asian descent and so I think with the
black and white he kind of looks like a
heart Conan but he's not he does look
like it and I also questioned I was like
why is this one shirtless and this one
isn't if you're fighting with blades why
would you fight shirtless yes and it
would make sense if it was a capture at
a treat he's just thrown into a ring and
then like fight yeah and it turns into a
really fun scene so we're excited oh my
God I'm so excited we made this video
with the help of geology and with their
help you can make your skin healthier
than ever geology is a 19 time
award-winning skin care and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
their products are built around just a
handful powerful proven ingredients that
have been trusted by dermatologists for
decades just take a 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology will create a simple
and effective skin care or hair care
routine customized just for you and look
at me I need that all the time geology's
co-wash and deodorant are great and I
use them literally again all the time
but right now they're running a special
offer for a skin care sampler pack in
geology skincare stuff is in a league of
its own geology's line of skin care
products can help you fight acne reduce
oiliness prevent wrinkles combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging and all
of these things apply to Yours Truly and
I look like a baby there's never been a
better time to try geology than right
now for a limited time use code new
rockstars 100 to get 100 off your
personalized 30-day skincare sample set
all you have to do is cover the 495 for
shipping on top of that new rockstars
fans get an exclusive bonus offer up to
50 off an additional skin hair and body
product of your choice when you add it
to your trial click the link in the
description or go to
g-e-o-l-o-g dot i e slash rockstars100
to get started later in the trailer we
meet Leah sedu who I probably pronounce
that name wrong and I'm so sorry I love
her as Margo fenring she's another Benny
Jesuit who we assume is planning to
procreate with fade Rafa they go in for
a little sweet sweet kiss they don't we
never see it it's the heat it's the heat
of them you got to pay the 16 bucks if
you want to see that kiss okay go to
IMAX go to the Dolby Theater right now
some assume Paul is dead so the Benny
Jesuit need to restructure their plan of
preserving in the bloodline so it makes
sense that they would kind of send
someone like that to fade right then we
get a glimpse of this woman in a spiral
hooded piece holding a fine looking
bottle this is probably the Water of
Life and later we see a scene where lady
Jessica is gasping for air just then
waking up and we assume she has probably
taken the Water of Life and is becoming
the Reverend mother in that shot with
the with the Water of Life could that be
a little worm in the bottom of the glass
I didn't see it there's a weird little
shape there now I don't know right like
Water of Life is kind of very connected
to the sand worms right and some
versions of it it comes from the worms
okay I'm sorry and maybe this is like
space tequila or Mezcal right where you
get the worm in the bottom I don't know
uh it could be just a reflection it's
very hard to tell in that brief Glimpse
we get that's a good idea because there
was something that I read up on that
they were like they have to drown the
baby sand worm in it until it gets out
it's like elixirs so if there is just a
baby sand worm that's that small that's
in the little bottle
oh okay the Water of Life is gonna be an
important part of this story right it is
kind of the holy water of the benad
Jesuit sisters it's what they have to
take to become a reverend mother status
like all important things in this
universe it's connected to the sand
worms and it kind of bestows on you this
deeper knowledge you literally inherit
the memories of everyone that's ever
lived it can like kind of break your
brain if you're not in the right place
or you're not the right kind of person
so yeah it's going to be super important
to both Jessica and Paul's future in
this movie we hear Paul setting up the
thumper to call the sand worm this scene
is intense it's very much living in the
moment it's slow everyone is super
worried about it the hooks Paul uses to
ride that big wormar called The Maker
Hooks and we really focus here on Paul's
first ride with the sand worm but we can
assume everyone the fremin rides a sand
worm it's not just Paul right yeah and
in fact probably hopefully we see a
bunch of them on the same worm maybe we
see a whole tangle of worms moving in
the same direction I also love that
moment on stillgar's face where it is
both awe of like oh I didn't think he
could write a sandworm like that but
there's is also a little right like the
fremens way is when somebody wants to
become leader they challenge the current
leader to a fight to the death right
that's kind of the their culture and so
maybe there's a little bit of
acknowledgment of like this kid's coming
for me yeah I'm I'm either gonna have to
kill Hammer he's gonna have to kill me
there's a little bit of an awareness and
maybe some sadness there in that face as
well yeah he didn't give any expression
even in the first movie where he almost
got his throat slid by Lady Jessica so
it's like this is a Monumental moment
that look wasn't something to just look
over we closed the trailer with Paul
saying with a knife chip and shatter and
we see Paul and Fred rotha about to
fight we also know that James says this
exact line to Paul in the first movie
before their fight when James dies I
also think you can see in the background
right like the way the sun is kind of
coming through the window there this is
taking place on arrakis right this is
not on Getty prime or some other world
so this is fade has come to Paul right
we know that's where this scene is
taking place it's kind of a very
important scene in the books and we'll
be in this film oh my god I didn't even
think about that that makes sense so now
in this trailer we're actually missing a
few key components right I mean like
trailers do they leave you up for
mystery we still never see the emperor
and Tim Blake Nelson and we think we
assume that he's married to Margot
fenring yes yeah and and he might be
playing like a former uh kind of
governor of Iraqis right during the
Imperial Reign there or we don't know
and again that might be a beast up or
tweaked role maybe some characters
getting combined because it's not a
really prominent role in the book so
that'll be interesting because again
he's a great actor so you think they're
probably bringing him in for something
important this is the part of our
breakdown where we are going to talk
about something so if you do not want
spoilers
turn off the video right now Bermuda for
a second and then come back at the end
when we plug a bunch of fun things so
but right now what do you want to share
about the spoilers because you actually
had a lot of information that I did not
know the first movie Paul kind of makes
a joke to his mom like hey the emperor
doesn't have any sons and he has this
his daughter why don't I just marry her
and that'll solve all these problems
well spoiler alert they do end up
getting married right uh now that
doesn't change his relationship with
Chinese kind of like a parallel to his
father's relationship with his comp
coupon his mom right like his father and
mother were never married she was a kind
of mine and so Chinese becomes his
concubine even though he's married to
Ireland
um and they're okay with that yeah well
oh my God I think they go along with it
because uh hey he's gonna be the leader
of the whole universe right this big
ultimate fight between team fade and
Paul is also paralleled by a gigantic
war between the fremin and what's left
of the Atreides and the harkonians and
the emperor's sardukar those badass
flying guys that come in with the little
swords that led the the initial
um uh fight on Eric Keen in the first
movie when they killed off most of the
Atreides right it's gonna be this
gigantic war in evil knew was talked
about how this is a big war movie and
we're gonna have these awesome huge
battle scenes right people riding in uh
giant worms word palaces dropping from
the sky hopefully we get some awesome
visuals right and then it kind of builds
to this one-on-one battle this kind of
like duel between Paul and fade it's
gonna be awesome I'm so excited for this
I am so excited for this and the
spoilers still don't make me not want to
see it it's like I'm more excited to see
how that's gonna guide up to this yes so
the other thing that we don't see in
this trailer that's important right is
Lady Jessica's daughter okay we knew in
the first movie she said she was
pregnant yeah she's pregnant throughout
this movie and she gives birth to a
daughter much like maybe smoking or
drinking alcohol while you're pregnant
on Earth uh you don't want to take a
Water of Life yes while you're pregnant
okay because it's hard enough for a
full-grown awesome adult to handle it an
infant in the womb uh she ends up coming
out having absorbed like a million years
of History it's gonna be very
interesting I think Danny Villanova said
it's gonna be a CGI character because
she's kind of mutated and morphed and is
not normal so I think it's really
interesting we don't see that character
either in this trailer I look forward to
seeing how he portrays her I am so
excited I'm so glad I didn't read any of
the spoilers that is insane that is yeah
is there any more is there anything else
uh no those are the big ones I mean yeah
we are so jazzed for this movie The
Spice must flow here at new rockstars
you can call us a rock stars
[Music]
that one worked I'll give you that one
that's it for Zach and eyes breakdown
for the latest dude part two trailer let
us know in the comments if you are
excited as us and if you want to support
the channel check out the awesome merch
check out the awesome merch at
nerdrive.com yeah and also tell them
that you want some Dune swag yes make
some sand worm swag and also I think
we're doing a live show yes if you're
see if you're watching this in the month
of May we're doing a live show here in
Los Angeles May 26th at the lyric
Hyperion theater but also if you're not
going to be in La you can live stream
that anywhere links to both get
in-person tickets and live stream
tickets will be in this video's
description thank you so much for having
me Jessica this would be my one and only
blue screen appearance no no uh it was
thank you for letting me tread the
boards here with you it's a delight oh
of course follow us everywhere you can
find us on social media make sure to
follow new rockstars for more breakdowns
of everything you love don't forget to
subscribe to our sister Channel The Deep
dive and thanks for watching bye thank
you
but it's over there
I should have got a knife
[Music]